(audience applauding)
- It's so awesome to have you!
- How are you?
- I'm so good!
- I've been cheering for you-
- [Kelly] Congratulations!
- I been cheering for you a long time so.
- Oh, that's so nice!
I'm a big fan as well.
I wanna talk about the
cover of your album,
this is adorable.
Wait, let's see the cover.
This is you on the album cover, right?
- Yeah!
(laughing)
This nine year old little
mischievous guy there.
(audience cooing)
- [Kelly] Look!
Look at you!
- The horns and the halo were authentic.
(audience laughing)
- You still got the boyish thing, though.
The horns and the halo, you were good-
- Yeah, I wore both of it.
- That's my son, too.
Yeah.
- I'm determined not to let
the 12-year-old in me die.
- Me too.
- Yeah.
- No, I think that's,
when you like stop growing,
you stop really living,
like I'm a total child about things.
- You gotta keep that imagination alive.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
Let go, yeah.
We get so serious as adults.
I love that.
So your name Killer Mike,
so where did that come from?
- I did not-
I would've named me Handsome Mike or-
- Yes, I like it.
I like it.
- So I had friends,
in rap you have posses or friends,
boys just naturally group together
and do stinky stuff, right?
- Yes.
- Either you're in the boy scouts
or you're a football player.
I was good at none of that.
(audience laughing)
And so I found my way with rapping
and my friends were like the
best rappers in the world to me
and there was one battle-
If you guys have seen 8 Mile,
there's a battle rap-
(audience cheering)
And guys didn't show up,
and other guys were just attacking my guys
but I'm like,
you know they're not there.
And I got angry as the kid in the group
and I just rapped against
everybody and slashed them.
It was like a Thor movie.
- Oh.
(audience cheering)
You used it as fuel.
I love it.
I'm so impressed by that.
Like that off the cuff-
like, that's incredible to me.
- I can't do it anymore
but when I was young,
it was amazing.
(audience laughing)
- I could never do it.
I was like, I'm so impressed.
It's a wonder I ever remember
lyrics ever, in general.
- I got the name that night, though.
A guy stopped the party, a
guy named Double D and said,
this kid's a killer.
And after that, no one ever
called me just Mike again.
It was Killer Mike.
- Aww.
(audience clapping)
That's awesome.
So, you've won Grammys,
but what is being nominated by your peers,
that's a different kind of thing.
What does that mean for you?
- Yeah, I currently have an altar
for my grandmother in my house
and the Grammy,
my first Grammy is broken,
because I kept it at her house.
I dropped out of Morehouse
and I told her in exchange for
dropping out and not bringing
her a college degree,
I gave her a Grammy.
She said it still ain't no degree and uh-
(audience laughing)
- Oh she said, next!
- She, education cared.
But she kept it in her house.
And I remember going to her
house one day and saying,
"Mama, where's the Grammy?
I don't see it."
- Yeah.
- And she put it in her closet.
I was like, "Why is it in the closet?"
Now, only our family is in the house.
She looked around and
said, "Cause people steal."
(audience laughing)
And I'm like, but they're our people.
"They still steal."
(audience laughing)
She, apparently,
a week or two later, she
dropped it and broke it
and she was ashamed to show me
and my sister told me to talk to her,
so I go and I talk to her,
I said, "Lemme see it."
And it's broken.
I said, "Mama, I love you."
It's not-
So I've never allowed
the Grammys to repair it.
But now it's time to get a
few more to keep it company.
- Look at that, yeah.
(audience clapping)
Just put a few more up there.
(Killer Mike laughing)
A family of Grammys.
- Exactly.
- I like it.
- And as an artist, your audience matter,
your fellow artists matter,
but I'm not gonna lie,
this year getting Rap Album of the Year
will mean everything in the world to me
because in the 50th year of hip hop,
I know for a fact I've made
the greatest representation
of hip hop this year.
- Yeah.
(audience clapping)
I love that certainty and
that confidence, yeah.
- I've made something that speaks to,
not only,
I grew up-
this little nine-year-old chubby Black kid
in this Black enclave in the Deep South,
but I grew up influenced by this music
that was self-organized by kids.
Kids in the South Bronx
self-organized around art,
dance, DJ, graffiti, MC-ing,
and they created a way out.
And my album honors that in a way
that none of the competition does,
and I love those guys.
Each of them are amazing and remarkable.
- Yeah.
- But in my opinion, and in
the opinion of the people
who are chiming in,
shouts out to Charlamagne for doing that.
There's no more cohesive
album for me that represents
the 50 years of hip hop.
(audience clapping)
- Absolutely.
Well let's do a commercial
break, everybody.
The Grammy-nominated
album, Michael, is out now.
Find it wherever you get
your music, go check it out.
We'll be right back with some more of
our holiday gift guide,
you're welcome in advance.